I'm sitting between I think the two most
employed people in NFL media radio shows
TV shows no but I mean what's it like
for both of you guys once you leave the
game you realize all right I gotta bust
my ass and work just as hard in my new
craft so like every opportunity is like
me being a rookie again and when I was a
rookie I walked in to the Minnesota
Vikings in I'm seeing Dante Culpepper in
anodized Minh fur and I'm seeing Randy
Moss swagged out with a baggy suit and
I'm like damn this is the NFL these
dudes pulling up and Bentley's with
spinners on it and I'm like baby I'm a
baby and I got to work not only to make
a name for myself but to like get these
guys attention and that was my goal to
get the greats attention so like what we
do now is if we got to work one two
three four jobs we want to get
attentions out of the masses because
we're still working like I would want to
jump off of something you said a few
minutes ago
where'd you brandy Moss yeah I was gonna
say you experienced the young Randy Moss
you experienced old random right the
first time I met Randy Moss I knew
immediately that if I got a atta boy pat
on the back from him I've arrived as a
wide receiver uh-huh but I went about it
the wrong way because I was trying to
get his attention like a thirsty dude at
the end of the night like I was like all
right as soon as I hit him with this
icebreaker we're gonna be best friends
forever man
and I remember one day I was I was
getting ready for practice and I think
was Jermaine Dupri it he had a music
video and he's wearing the Marshall 88
Jersey so I'm like in my little dorm
room at Jenkins like this is it man and
I remember us doing conditioning and I'm
standing next to him I'm literally like
gasps and myself up like I do bout to
walk across the bar and ask a girl for
the number uh Randy voice is cracking
I'm a grown man
I was like did you see that remain do
pre video yeah add your Jersey on there
and he's running next to me he looks at
me he just keeps all right now is crowd
listen I wrote a girl a note do you like
me yes you know in the fifth grade and
she crumpled it up and threw it at my
face Oh Randy mom hurt me more like my
feelings were crushed and I was like
damn I blew it
and there was crazy is like once I
started making plays
like that's when he came and was like
all right like I know you love the game
and I know you're one of the good ones
it's funny I think to hear him say that
because I don't think people always
realize that football players can also
be fanboys first time Randy Moss came on
the plane I missed row 27 by the window
and he said can I sit here I was like
yeah yeah I mean that's the way I felt
but the like Nate's saying - the one
thing I learned from him in our hurry is
his perspective on the game was like
amazing he could almost see the game
almost like a quarterback you understood
offense and defense and you know he
understood when this play was stupid and
he wasn't gonna tell the coach that's a
stupid play Sims I see you know what it
was yeah I mean and I just I really
enjoyed being around
Calvin is the forgotten guy yeah if I'm
creating a player in Madden he's six
five running a four three and his name
is Calvin Johnson yeah but he's never
mentioned in the Jerry Rice tee Oh Randy
Moss top three but I would argue his
physically as gifted as any of them if
not more no question I mean it's the
same individual that broke Jerry Rice's
single-season record yeah I watched him
do it
I watched games where he'll put up a
buck 90 and we go to the meeting and
after a loss Shaun Jefferson was a
former player why receiver he was our
wide receivers coach he say Calvin I
need you to do more no I'm thinking like
damn what you want to do go for 250 and
Calvin would say anything
he was quiet you know his mother a
doctor daddy worked on the real world so
he had this blend of blue-collar and
high IQ and that was his approach to
life and he was just not as hit say all
right coach next game and go put up 300
now Randy was just pure speed and
capsulated if they put shoulder pads and
cleats on his same boat and he was
actually a good football player that can
catch and track the ball like no other
yeah it would be Randy Moss and Randy
Moss had the greatest late hands ever
even though coaches say don't panic
remember your cues don't give anything
away like we panic like we don't
remember our cues and we give everything
away like the ball is in the air you
start hearing your own breath and you go
from and if you're a really good DB I
know it's a small detail but you could
hear a guy breathing hard and then you
see his eyes go from here to here yes
and that
right there is a cue that something's
coming right Randy would like a look and
the ball would be coming and his face
doesn't move his hands doesn't move his
breath doesn't move and then right when
it gets to him he's like velcro like
that's something that's you might not
see ever and that's not something you
coach it's something that God said hey
Randy I got a little extra for you right
whew the man that was awesome